>>> IN OUR HEALTH LE, TAKING A
DAILY MULTVITAMIN COULD BE A
HEALTH BENEFIT FOR YOUR BODY AND
BRAIN.
A NEW STUDY FROM THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION SUGGESTIONS IT MAY
SLOW COGNITIVE DECLINE IN OLDER
ADULTS.
TO HELP DESCRIBE THIS
ENCOURAGING DISEASE TO BATTLE AS
TIMERS AND DEMENTIA.
TELL US MORE ABOUT THIS STUDY.
>> THIS WAS A STUDY OF 2200
OLDER AMERICANS, OVER 65,
AVERAGE AGE OF 72.
RESEARCHERS WANTED TO SEE IF
THEY GOT A SUPPLEMENT, COCOA
EXTRACT OR MULTI VITAMIN COULD
THEY PROTECT THEIR COGNITIVE
FUNCTION.
THEY GAVE THEM A COGNITIVE TEST
AT BASELINE AND TEST THEM YEAR
ONE, TWO AND THREE.
ESSENTIALLY, THEY THOUGHT THEY
MIGHT FIND A BENEFIT WITH THE
COCO AS TRACT GROUP.
THEY DID NOT.
THEY FOUND A BENEFIT IN THE
MULTI VITAMIN GROUP.
IT SLOWED THE DECLINE OF
COGNITIVE AGEING BY 60%.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, IN THE
PATIENTS OR SUBJECTS WITH
UNDERLYING CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE, THEY SAW MORE BENEFIT.
>> PEOPLE SEEM EXCITED ABOUT
THIS.
WHY OTHER THAN THE OBVIOUS
REASONS, WHY DO YOU THINK IT IS
SO INTERESTING?
>> PRIOR REVIEWS OF NUTRITION
SUPPLEMENTS SHOWN INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE FOR COGNITIVE FUNCTION.
THIS IS THE LARGE SCALE
RANDOMIZED CONTROL STUDY TO SHOW
A POTENTIAL BENEFIT.
THERE IS NO FDA APPROVED
INTERVENTIONS TO PROTECT
COGNITIVE FUNCTION.
WHEN YOU THINK OF THE POTENTIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT WITH
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS A MULTI
VITAMIN THAT'S SAFE, ACCESSIBLE,
AFFORDABLE IF IT IS EFFECTIVE,
YOU COULD HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
HELP MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
6.5 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
WHEN YOU LOOK WORLDWIDE, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT 46 MILLION ADULTS
WHO SUFFER FROM ALZHEIMER'S
DEMENTIA OR SOME FORM OF
DEMENTIA.
SO REAL POTENTIAL.
>> SO WHAT ARE THE TAKE AWAYS?
WHAT SHOULD PEOPLE AT HOME BE
DOING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THEY'RE
WATCHING US?
>> IT'S PRACTICED
OR GUIDELINED CHANGING YET.
UNTIL PRELIMINARY.
ONE STUDY, IMPORTANT TO
REPLICATE IT IN LARGER STUDIES,
STUDIES WITH A MORE DIVERSE
POPULATION.
AND WHAT WE REALLY COUNSEL
PEOPLE FOR IN GENERAL IS TO EAT
A WELL-BALANCED DIET.
THERE'S TONS OF BIOACTIVE
NUTRIENTS IN A GOOD DIET AND YOU
CAN GET THEM THAT WAY.
THERE ARE CERTAIN POPULATIONS
THAT CERTAINLY NEED
SUPPLEMENTATION AND THEN THERE
ARE OTHER LOW-COST STRATEGIES
THAT YOU CAN DO TO IMPROVE YOUR
COGNITIVE FUNCTION, THINGS LIKE
EXERCISE, MANAGING YOUR STRESS,
SLEEP, AVOIDING TOO MUCH ALCOHOL
OR CIGARETTES, SOCIAL
STIMULATION, MENTAL STIMULATION,
SO THESE ARE EASY STRATEGIES TO
USE.
>> AND I HAD HEARD IN THE PAST,
PEOPLE IN THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT
SUPPLEMENTS.
>> I'M SO GLAD YOU ASKED THIS
QUESTION BECAUSE THIS COMES UP
ALL THE TIME, AND MANY TIMES,
PATIENTS DON'T ACTUALLY TELL YOU
THEY'RE TAKING SUPPLEMENTS, SO
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS TO ASK THAT
QUESTION, ARE YOU TAKING
SUPPLEMENTS?
AND TO REVIEW WITH PATIENTS WHAT
THEY'RE TAKING.
THE SUPPLEMENT INDUSTRY IS NOT
REGULATED BY THE FDA AS DRUGS.
THEY'RE REGULATED AT FOODS SO
THEY GET PUT OUT ON THE MARKET
WITHOUT HAVING TO PROVE SAFETY.
THE LABELS MAY NOT ALWAYS BE
ACCURATE, SO THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY CASES OF SUPPLEMENTS HAVING
CONTAMINANTS IN THEM, HEAVY
METALS, OTHER CHEMICALS AND
DRUGS.
SOMETIMES THEY CAN INTERACT WITH
PRESCRIPTION MEDS YOU'RE TAKING
AND PEOPLE HAVE ENDED UP IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM AND HOSPITALIZED
BECAUSE OF SUPPLEMENT USE.
MULTIVITAMINS IN GENERAL ARE
PROBABLY RELATIVELY SAFE BUT
EVEN THOSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
DISCUSS WITH YOUR PRIMARY CARE
DOCTOR.
THIS IS WHAT I'M TAKING, IS IT
OKAY, BECAUSE IN SOMETIME
PATIENT POPULATIONS WHO HAVE
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS OR ARE
TAKING OTHER DRUGS, IT MAY NOT
BE OKAY.
>> IF YOU'RE WONDERING WHY
THEY'RE NOT REGULATED BY T